le choeur touche toutes les maladies de
coeur peut toucher aussi pas engendrer
des problèmes psychiatriques mais aussi
nous avons une grande dune pato une part
d'une population qui est vieillissante
et cette population vieillissante va
avoir de plus en plus des problèmes
cardiovasculaires et donc il était
intéressant d'avoir non seulement la vie
des cardiologues mais aussi de nos deux
confrères spécialistes des autres des
autres spécialités
alors effectivement comme vous l'avez
dit y aura des psychiatres il y aura des
jérémiades mais aussi des
endocrinologues des diabétologues des
médecins vasculaires tout une toute une
tout le panel de la médecine sera
représenté à ces journées ça permet
d'échanger des problématiques locales et
de avec des experts des experts
métropolitain de discuter avec eux des
possibilités de traitements innovants
par rapport à des pathologies
particulières que l'on peut avoir
voir apparaître et aussi des pathologies
ancien mais qui explosent aux antilles
guyane et contenus sont très importants
dans le sens où ça va aborder tous les
thèmes de la cardiologie toutes les
pathologies inhérentes à la cardiologie
et surtout ça va amener au cardiologue
de tous les éléments de nouveauté
récente avec des intervenants venant de
métropole que
la guyane que de tous les deux tout le
bassin antillo guyanais et qui vont nous
amener dans les informations des
nouveautés sur les techniques sur les
nouveaux traitements et sur les de
toutes ces pathologies pouvant
apparaître aux antilles